'M
MADDIE HASSON. THIS IS THE
MONTH THAT COULD DEFINE
JOE BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY
AND
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY
FOR EIGHT MONTHS. NOW, THE
PRESIDENT'S PARTY IS HELD A
MAJORITY IN BOTH HOUSES OF
CONGRESS
AND FAILED TO GET MUCH OF HIS
LEGISLATIVE AGENDA PASSED.
THAT MIGHT CHANGE. NOW
AS LAWMAKERS RETURN TO
WASHINGTON, AND DEMOCRATS
DRILL DOWN ON THE DETAILS,
IN THEIR VOTING RIGHTS
LEGISLATION,
AS WELL AS THEIR
THREE POINT. FIVE TRILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET, RECONCILIATION
BILL.
AND
BOTH
ARE SORELY NEEDED ON VOTING
RIGHTS,
REPUBLICANS CONTINUE TO PUSH
FOR RESTRICTIONS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO RE-LITIGATE THE
2020 ELECTION AND TO
PREEMPTIVELY LABEL NEW
ELECTIONS. LIKE TODAY'S,
CALIFORNIA RECALL AND
NOVEMBER'S VIRGINIA GOVERNOR'S
ELECTION
RIGGED
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE
TWICE HOUSE, DEMOCRATS HAVE
PASSED LANDMARK BILLS TO
PRESERVE AND EXPAND THE
FRANCHISE
THE JOHN LEWIS
VOTING RIGHTS ACT AND THE FOR
THE
PEOPLE ACT AND TWICE THOSE
BILLS
STALLED IN THE
IN THE SENATE.
THANKS TO THE
FILIBUSTER. SO DEMOCRATS NOW
ARE ADVANCING A NEW
COMPROMISE BILL, THE FREEDOM
TO VOTE ACT THAT
BILL DOES AWAY WITH
PROGRESSIVE PLANS TO EXPAND
PUBLIC FINANCING OF
ELECTIONS AND END PARTIES AND
DEADLOCK ON THE
FEDERAL ELECTION COMMISSION.
IT ALSO GIVES LOCAL ELECTION
OFFICIALS A FREE HAND TO
PURGE VOTER ROLLS, AND
GIVE STATES MORE LATITUDE TO
CREATE VOTER IDS.
HMM. IT DOES HOWEVER
MAKE ELECTION DAY A FEDERAL
HOLIDAY. IT ALSO PROVIDES FOR
EARLY VOTING AND
MAIL-IN VOTING.
SHOULD WIDE AND
INCLUDES CRUCIAL
ELECTION, SUBVERSION
PROVISIONS, THAT WOULD MAKE IT
HARDER FOR STATE OFFICIALS.
GOP STATE OFFICIALS TO
OVERRIDE ELECTION RESULTS.
MUCH OF THIS
COMPROMISING WAS DONE AT THE
BEHEST OF SUPPOSEDLY
DEMOCRATIC. SENATOR, JOE,
MANCHIN OF WEST VIRGINIA,
WHO SAYS HE WANTS
A VOTING BILL, THAT TEN
REPUBLICANS WILL VOTE FOR IN A
BIPARTISAN MANNER.
THEREBY?
OVERCOMING THE FILIBUSTER,
NOT ALL OF HIS COLLEAGUES ARE
SOLD ON THAT APPROACH.
SENATOR MANCHIN KEEPS.
REMINDING EVERYBODY. HOW THE
PREFERENCE IS ALWAYS TO WORK
ON A BIPARTISAN FASHION
AND WHAT WE CAN'T, THAT'S
WHAT ARE OUR FUNDAMENTAL
VOTING RIGHTS ARE SO
IMPORTANT. SO CRITICAL. I
THINK THERE
WERE NOT SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING
TEN REPUBLICANS TO DO THE
RIGHT THING THAT WE HAVE
NO CHOICE, BUT TO REVISIT THE
RULES OF THE
SENATE.
OF COURSE,
MANSION STRANGE BREW OF
SELF-INTEREST AND
SMARM AS ALSO ENDANGERED THE
DEMOCRATS,
SIGNATURE LEGISLATION, THE
THREE POINT FIVE TRILLION
DOLLAR, BUDGET, RECONCILIATION
BILL, THAT WOULD RAISE TAXES
ON THE RICHEST AMERICANS
AND SPENT
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNTS,
TACKLING CLIMATE, CHANGE
A GROWING PRIORITY FOR
PROGRESSIVES IS SUMMER IN
WHICH ONE IN THREE
AMERICANS HAVE, ENDURED AN
EXTREME
CLIMATE RELATED DISASTER,
ACCORDING TO THE WASHINGTON
POST
IN THE LATEST SUCH EMERGENCY
TROPICAL STORM. NICHOLAS HAS
BROUGHT PUNISHED.
FLOODING TO THE SOUTH JUST
AFTER THE EASTERN SEABOARD
WAS
WRECKED BY HURRICANE, IDA AND
CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE, OF
COURSE TO FIGHT WILDFIRES.
LESS
MANSION SAID THIS WEEKEND THAT
THE RECONCILIATION
BILLS PRICE TAG WAS A
NON-STARTER FOR HIM.
SO, YOU'RE NOT AGAINST THIS,
YOU COULD SUPPORT THIS
THREE-AND-A-HALF TRAIN, OUR
PLANET NOT SUPPORT. OKAY, SO
THAT IS
NOW WE'RE GETTING TO BRAD.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW SCURRYING TO
COME UP WITH EVEN MORE
COMPROMISES THIS TIME ON
SPENDING TAXING AND CLIMATE.
THAT MIGHT PLACATE MANSION,
BUT CAN ANY CLIMATE BILL
REALLY SATISFY HIM?
THIS IS AS GOOD A TIME AS ANY
TO REMIND VIEWERS THAT MANSION
MADE HIS PERSONAL FORTUNE AS
IT COLD BROKER AND THAT
HE REPRESENTS A BIG
COAL PRODUCING STATE IN THE
SENATE, BUT YOU KNOW, WHAT
ALL WE EVER HEAR ABOUT IS THE
CONCERNS OF DEMOCRATIC
MODERATES, QUOTE UNQUOTE, LIKE
JOE MANCHIN AND ARIZONA
SENATOR KISSED IN CINEMA, WHO
ALSO
OBJECTS
TO THE
THREE POINT FIVE TRILLION
DOLLAR BILL, BUT THE
REALITY IS THAT
PROGRESSIVES HAVE AS MUCH
LEVERAGE AS THEY DO,
ESPECIALLY IN THE HOUSE WHERE
NANCY PELOSI
MAJORITY HINGES ON JUST A FEW
SEATS AND AT LEAST ONE OF
THOSE
PROGRESSIVES, CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRA. OCASIO, CORTEZ HAS
SAID SHE'LL USE THAT LEVERAGE
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S
COMPROMISES AND UP LOOKING
LIKE A
SURRENDER.
YES,
NOTHING WOULD GIVE
ME MORE.
PLAYIN ARE DARK MONEY. FOSSIL
FUEL EX ON LOBBYISTS
DRAFTED
ENERGY,
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
IF THEY COME AFTER OUR CHILD
CARE AND
AND CLIMATE PRIORITIES.
WHO BETTER TO TALK TO ABOUT
ALL OF THIS
THAN A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
PROGRESSIVE
SQUAD EARLIER TODAY? I SPOKE
WITH MASSACHUSETTS.
CONGRESSWOMAN DIANA PRESLEY
ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS
TIGHTENING WINDOW FOR
LEGISLATION AND THE SIMMERING
TENSIONS BETWEEN THE
PARTIES CENTRIST AND THE
PROGRESSIVES.
CONGRESSWOMAN DIANA, PRESLEY
OF MASSACHUSETTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US ON THE
SHOW TONIGHT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT ONE ISSUE
THAT THIS MAJOR
RECONCILIATION BILL PUTS FRONT
AND CENTER,
CLIMATE CHANGE. JUST
YESTERDAY. YOU
PUBLISHED AN OP-ED IN THE
BOSTON GLOBE SAYING THAT
INVESTMENT IN CLIMATE
INFRASTRUCTURE. CANNOT WAIT.
REPUBLICANS AND SOME OF YOUR
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES
DISAGREE. THEY SAY IT'S PORK.
IT'S A DISTRACTION. WHAT DO
YOU SAY TO
THEM?
CLIMATE IS
INFRASTRUCTURE. AGAIN. WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS
AND TRADITIONAL FORMS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE,
BUT WE DO INFRASTRUCTURE IS
MORE THAN PHYSICAL AND IT'S
HUMID AS WELL. AND THIS IS A
MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH.
WE KNOW THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO OUR
PLANET AND CERTAINLY THE MOST
VULNERABLE
LOW INCOME, COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR, HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY CLIMATE,
HIGHER RATES OF ASTHMA. MORE
TO EXTREME WEATHER. VEL RISE.
MY DISTRICT. THE BEST USE OF
SEVERAL CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT
WAS
THE HARDEST, HIT IN OUR
CONGRESSIONAL, DELEGATION IN
THE COMMONWEALTH. AND
IF YOU LINE UP
THOSE
HIGHEST
ASTHMA RATE WITH THE HIGHEST
RATES OF
COPAN, INFECTION,
HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH
WITH OUR HEAT MAPS,
THEY SYNC UP
PERFECTLY SO WE HAVE GOT TO
MAKE THESE ROBUST
INVESTMENTS AND
WE THINGS THAT I'M CALLING FOR
AS A CIVILIAN CONSERVATION
CORPS.
A TRANSITION TO RENEWABLE
ENERGY AND INVESTMENT
FROM FOSSIL FUELS. SO
THIS IS A
MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH AND
IT IS A VERB
AND DISPROPORTIONATE BORE BY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR,
GIVEN PROXIMITY TO
HIGHWAYS
TOXIC WASTE JOBS
TO TRANSPORTATION
DESERTS
FOOD APARTHEID SYSTEM,
UNEQUAL, ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
AGAIN, HIGHEST RATES OF
ASTHMA. SO THIS IS ALSO A
RACIAL JUSTICE
ISSUE.
IT IS INDEED, ALTHOUGH ONE OF
THE BIG OBSTACLES TO THE
RECONCILIATION
BILL'S PASSAGE, ESPECIALLY THE
CLIMATE STUFF IN IT IS
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR, JOE,
MANCHIN OF WEST VIRGINIA. WHO
ALSO JUST HAPPENS TO CHAIR THE
SENATE ENERGY AND NATURAL
RESOURCES
COMMITTEE.
HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN TO YOUR
VOTERS AND TO CLIMATE
ACTIVISTS AND TO YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT
THE
WE'LL MAKE A WRITING THE
LEGISLATION ON CLIMATE CHANGE
IN THE SENATE, MADE HIS
FORTUNE AS A COLD BROKER
AND ENJOYS THE BACKING OF
BIG: BIG OIL. HOW IS THAT NOT
A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST?
WELL, IT CERTAINLY IS
AND I THINK SENATOR MANCHIN
OWES, THE PEOPLE OF WEST
VIRGINIA
AND EXPLANATION BECAUSE
HE IS NOT
PRIORITIZING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE,
WE HAVE GOT TO MAKE THESE BOLD
INVESTMENTS,
THREE POINT. FIVE CHILDREN WAS
ALREADY A COMPROMISE
AND THIS IS SIMPLY THE COST OF
MAKING UP FOR LONG OVERDUE.
DIVESTMENT AND
UNDER INVESTMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES, AND THE COSTS ARE
COVERED,
YOU KNOW, IF WE STAY THE
COURSE AND WE TAX THE
RICHEST OF THE RICH.
IT'S A
SIMPLE SOLUTION.
BUT
YOU KNOW,
JOE MANCHIN
ISN'T IN CHARGE. THANK GOD,
THE PEOPLE ARE AND I'M GOING
TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR THEM.
THEN WE
ADVANCE A BOLD
BUILT WITH ROBUST
INVESTMENTS THAT MEETS THE
NEEDS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHEN THEY ARE URGENT AS THEY
BEAR THE WEIGHT OF
THESE
CONVERGENT CRISES
A PUBLIC HEALTH,
PANDEMIC
AND CRISIS, A PANDEMIC
IS DUE TO RECESSION AND AGAIN
A NATIONAL RECKONING ON RACIAL
INJUSTICE. SO CARE IS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HOUSING IS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CLIMATE IS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
ANOTHER OBSTACLE
TO
PROGRESSIVE SPENDING
GOALS IS ARIZONA,
SENATOR KISSED IN CINEMA, WHO
STAFF
AND PEOPLE AROUND US SEEM TO
BRIEF AXIOS YESTERDAY THAT SHE
HAS AN ACCOUNTANT LIKE FOCUS
ON THE BOTTOM LINE AND IS
ARMED WITH OUR OWN
SPREADSHEETS ABOUT THE COSTS
AND TAX HIKES NEEDED FOR EACH
PROGRAM.
I MEAN, ASIDE FROM IT BEING A
BIT PATRONIZING.
IS IT THE CASE THAT
SENATOR CINEMA
UNDERSTANDS MOUTH AND THE
PROGRESSIVES
DON'T
WELL, I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE. THAT ALTHOUGH THERE
IS A TENDENCY
TO
MALIGN AND TO
MARGINALIZE WHERE CONSIDERED
PROGRESSIVE PRIORITIES
THESE IDEAS.
THESE POLICIES ARE ACTUALLY
WILDLY POPULAR
AND THAT IS BECAUSE THEY MEET
THE MOMENT
IN ORDER FOR US TO
REALLY MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. WE'VE GOT TO
MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS.
BUT MOREOVER IN ORDER FOR US
TO KEEP OUR WORD.
WHAT IS THE FOURTH OF
DEMOCRATS? HAVING THE
HOUSE, THE SENATE AND THE
WHITE HOUSE
WE HAVE A
MAJORITY THAT WAS DELIVERED TO
US BY DIVERSE
COALITION OF
MULTI-GENERATIONAL,
MULTI RACIAL ISSUES
BASED ACTIVISTS AND VOTERS.
AND WE NEED TO DELIVER TO
THEM. SO THEY HAVE GIVEN US
THE MAJORITY
IT ALONG WITH THAT A MANDATE
AND BEING IN THE MAJORITY MUST
BE NO MORE THAN A TALKING
POINT. IT IS ABOUT
IMPACT AND US DELIVERING FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
ANTIQUATED
A SENATE PROCESS.
OR WASHINGTON PROCEDURES,
THEY CARE ABOUT IMPACT.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M FOCUSED
ON, YOU KNOW, THE BEST ADVICE
I RECEIVED AS A FRESHMAN,
THREE YEARS AGO
WAS IN THE PROCESS OF
LEGISLATION GOVERNING. IT'S
VERY EASY TO FORGET THE
PLOT AND THE PLOT IS THE
PEOPLE THAT WE MUST NEVER LOSE
SIGHT OF THEM. AND I CERTAINLY
MAKE SURE I REMAIN CONNECTED
IN A COMMUNITY WITH THE PEOPLE
THAT I REPRESENT.
SO THE TIME IN PROXIMITY TO
THEIR
HURT AND I'M NOT,
WHO'S THINGS ARE NOT ABSTRACT
FOR
ME.
CONGRESSMAN ON VOTING RIGHTS,
EVEN THOUGH HOUSE DEMOCRATS
HAVE PASTOR JOHN LEWIS VOTING
RIGHTS ACT AND THE FOR THE
PEOPLE ACT THEY'VE BEEN
STALLED IN THE SENATE.
NOW THERE'S THIS
DEMOCRATIC COMPROMISE BILL,
THE FREEDOM TO VOTE ACT THAT
APPROVES VOTER, ID AND DROPS
EFFORTS TO REFORM. THE FEC
WILL YOU AND OTHER HOUSE
PROGRESSIVES ACCEPT?
THIS SLIM DOWN
BILL?
IT'S THE BARE MINIMUM OF WHAT
WE SHOULD BE DOING, YOU KNOW,
CERTAINLY WHAT YOU KNOW, I
WOULD PREFER IS THAT WE
ABOLISH THE FILIBUSTER AND
THAT WE PASS THE JOHN
LEWIS LONELY RIGHTS ACT THAT
WE PASSED THE FOR THE PEOPLE
ASKED.
SO THIS IS JUST THE
BARE MINIMUM OF WHAT WE REALLY
SHOULD
WE DO IT. I MEAN,
SO, WHILE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE
DISENFRANCHISEMENT OF MILLIONS
OF VOTERS,
DISPROPORTIONATELY
VOTERS OF COLOR,
DISABLED VOTERS, AND THE
ELDERLY.
PROGRESSIVES ARE ALSO DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS SUMMER'S
GOP ATTACK ON REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS
AFTER REBUFFING A CHALLENGE.
THE NEW TEXAS LAW THAT
EFFECTIVELY BANS, ABORTION SIX
WEEKS AFTER CONCEPTION
THE SUPREME COURT IS NOW
TAKING UP A SIMILAR
MISSISSIPPI LAW. IN A CASE
THAT COULD PUT THE FINAL NAIL
IN ROE VERSUS WADE COUGHING
IF THERE WAS EVER A STRONG
CASE FOR REFORMING, OR EVEN
EXPANDING THE SUPREME COURT,
ISN'T IT NOW? WHY ARE WE
HEARING MORE ABOUT
COURT REFORM FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
WELL, BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN
THE HURT AND HARM INFLICTED
BY THE
EXTREMISM
OF THE SUPREME COURT,
WHETHER YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
HOUSING RIGHTS, VOTING RIGHTS
OR REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM,
THEY HAVE HAD.
BY MY VANTAGE POINT
CONTEMPT FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE
AND ARE WORKING TO
ERODE AT
HUMAN AND CIVIL RIGHTS THAN WE
THOUGHT, AND ORGANIZED
A HARD TO EARN.
AND SO THIS IS NOT A NEW
CONVERSATION. AND IN FACT, IT
IS
NOT EVEN FROM
EXCITING CONGRESS HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO DO IT.
WE'VE DONE IT SEVEN TIMES.
CONGRESSMAN MONITOR JONES
INTRODUCED A BILL OF WHICH I'M
A CO-SPONSOR
TO EXPAND THE FORTS AND SO,
YOU KNOW WHAT, I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IS THAT WE BRING TO
THE FLOOR.
MY BILL
WOULD REPRESENT OF JUDY CHU. I
THANK HER FOR HER LEADERSHIP
YEARS.
I CHAIR THE ABORTION RIGHTS
AND ACCESS TASK FORCE
OUT OF THE PRO-CHOICE CAUCUS.
THIS IS THE FIRST
PRO-CHOICE MAJORITY CONGRESS
IN THE HISTORY OF CONGRESS.
THAT
HAS TO MEAN
SOMETHING WE NEED TO BRING THE
WOMEN'S HEALTH PROTECTION ACT
TO THE FLOOR FOR A VOTE
TO CODIFY
WORLDVIEW. WADE, WHICH IS
AGAIN
POPULAR AND ALSO NECESSARY
FOR REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM AND
WITH
BAN, THE
INTRODUCE YOU INTRODUCTION OF
OTHER HARMFUL AND DRACONIAN
STATE LAWS. LIKE WHAT
WHAT IN TEXAS
WE'RE ALMOST OUT OF TIME, BUT
I HAVE TO ASK A QUESTION ABOUT
YOUR PROGRESSIVE SQUAD
COLLEAGUE, ALEXANDER. IT
CAUSED HER. CORTEZ. SHE SORT
OF A SOCIAL MEDIA
FURORE YESTERDAY, AFTER
ATTENDING THE MAP
GALLERY AND A DESIGNER DRESS
WITH THE MESSAGE TAX THE RICH.
EMBLAZONED ACROSS HER BACK.
QUITE THE STATEMENT IN A
GALLERY, FULL OF MONEY.
DELETE. WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF
THAT? SOME PEOPLE ARE SAYING
SHE SHOULDN'T HAVE EVEN GONE.
WELL, SHE HAS A PLATFORM
AND SHE'S USING IT
BOTH TO
STORED
DISCOURSE AND DEBATE AND TO
ADVANCE
POLICY.
AND SO
OUR COSINE TAX DIRECTION AGAIN
FOR THOSE, THAT WOULD ARGUE
THAT FOR ALL OF THESE BOLD
INVESTMENTS, THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE AND HOUSING
CARE AND CLIMATE TO MEET
THE MOMENT IN THIS ONCE IN A
GENERATION OPPORTUNITY.
ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME
OPPORTUNITY TO REVERSE
CENTURIES OF HER TO ADVANCE
ONCE-IN-A-GENERATION,
OPPORTUNITY,
ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY
TO REVERSE CENTURIES OF HER TO
YOU KNOW, WE CAN PAY FOR THESE
THINGS. THERE'S NOT A DEFICIT
OF RESOURCE. THERE IS A
DEFICIT OF EMPATHY AND
PRIORITIZATION.
SO, CONGRESSWOMAN IF
THE TAXING, THE RICH PART OF
THIS BUDGET RECONCILIATION
DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE POINTING OUT
THAT THE HOUSE WAYS AND MEANS
COMMITTEES PROPOSAL. DOESN'T
GO FAR ENOUGH FOR THE SUPER
RIDGE WILL PROGRESS. IS LIKE
YOURSELF, USE YOUR LEVERAGE
IN THE SAME WAY THAT
MANSION OR CINEMA HAVE IN THE
SENATE TO BLOCK
RIGHT NOW, I'M FOCUSED ON
ADVANCING THESE PROGRESSIVE
POLICY OF THE CAUSES OF THE,
MY CONSTITUENTS, AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING UNPRECEDENTED
HEARD. SO I'M STAYING AT THE
TABLE. I'M GOING TO CONTINUE
TO FIGHT FOR THIS
RECONCILIATION TO BE AS BOLD
AS POSSIBLE TO MEET THE
MOMENT AND
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND BEYOND THAT, YOU KNOW, WE
SHALL SEE. BUT I DON'T UNTIL
THE INK IS DRY
AND THERE IS A VOTE
IMMEDIATELY IN FRONT OF ME.
WHAT I'M FOCUSED ON IS JUST
MAKING THOSE
MAKING THE
HAVE
ALREADY AND WE HAVE A MANDATE
AND WE NEED TO ACT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WE'RE OUT OF TIME.
BUT CONGRESSWOMAN DIANA
PRESLEY. APPRECIATE YOU COMING
ON THE SHOW TODAY.